[Music]
evan is with us in sterling
virginia hi evan how are you
doing very well phil how are you better
than i deserve what's up
so uh
just coming up here soon wait a minute
you're not talking directly into your
phone we can't hear you try again
oh no
can you hear me now yes sir yeah okay um
so looking at a few life changes coming
up soon um
about 10 months ago me and my wife had
our first daughter yay
super awesome super happy
um my wife is a teacher and i'm a
photographer together we bring home
about 80 000 ish give or take a year
but with the craziness that has been
going on in the school systems here in
virginia
uh my wife has kind of hit her limit
uh as well as she's really looking to
kind of stay home with our daughter
um and we are currently
fluctuating back and forth between baby
step two and one
um
and i was just wondering she's planning
on uh leaving her job in june so that's
about seven months
ish how much debt do you have left
um we have a combined
total of like 26 000.
what does she teach
second grade
reading then
uh basically yeah yeah
so i mean that's one of the key elements
of teaching second grade typically so uh
well
what i was reaching for is this between
now and june i want her to begin to to
build a robust
tutoring
company where she tutors
grade schoolers on reading
okay and she can make more doing that
than she can in the classroom if you
build it crazy money
and she's in complete control of her
environment then
which is what she's complaining about
now right
right and she can do that and still be
around your baby
that's very true that she was talking
about trying to figure out
a way if she's at home to possibly make
some money i think she can make more
than she makes now
okay cool but let's start the business
now
okay launch it in january
get it all mapped out start studying
what tutors charge where they get their
customers how are you going to get
people to come and they're going to come
to your house are they going to come
somewhere else and how are you going to
run this business and how you're going
to build up front by the way and um
you know and are you going to sell
packages by the hour or how are you
going to do it and how do other tutors
in your area price and where do they
advertise and you got to build a
business now
and you got seven months to do it
yes sir and you might have to look at
your photography operation and say what
do i got to do differently now because
we're in this together this is a team
and our global income is going to shift
for a season yeah you're going to gear
up so you may have to take more jobs
different jobs you may have to go get a
uh clock in glock out shot who knows but
you got to be honest with yourself about
your photography business and what
tomorrow's gonna look like for your
whole household too right yeah so here's
the thing the point being you're gonna
be out of debt by the time she quits but
you don't even have to take a step back
in income when she quits
okay
household i think you can build it out
hold on i'll have laura send you a copy
of christy wright's business boutique
book
equipping women to make money doing what
they love
that's the name of the book
so uh
exactly where you are here
yeah
we've got an exodus of teachers man it's
brilliant we've been an exodus of people
in a lot of fields service industries a
lot of fields and it has more to do with
politics than it does actually the field
unbelievable and you know we're losing
some of our best
servants in every area of our world
so sad